>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
TUCKER, THANK YOU FROM THE
SWAMP IN D.C.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
LIKE A FALSE PROPHET
RIGHTEOUSNESS, JAMES COMEY,
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
CONSTANTLY PRETENDING TO BE
A COURAGEOUS HERO FIGHTING
FOR TRUTH AND JUSTICE.
IN REALITY, IS HE A HATEFUL,
VENGEFUL, AIR GANTZ
NARCISSIST.
WE NOW KNOW WHO ABUSED POWER
AND FOSTERED ONE OF THE MOST
CORRUPT FEDERAL DEPARTMENTS
THIS COUNTRY HAS EVER SEEN.
TONIGHT WE CAN REPORT THE
WALLS ARE CLOSING IN ON
JAMES COMEY.
WE HAVE, YET, ANOTHER MAJOR
DEVELOPMENT IN OUR HANNITY
WATCH ON THE DEEP STATE.
FORMER FBI GENERAL COUNSEL
JAMES BAKER OF THE MAN WHO
SERVED AS JIM COMEY'S TOP
LAWYER.
>> HE TOO LIKE OTHERS SUNDAY
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION FOR
LEAKING TO THE MEDIA AND
BAKER HAS LONG FACED
SCRUTINY OVER HIS TIES TO
MOTHER JONES REPORTER DAVID
CORN.
REMEMBER CORN WAS THE FIRST
JOURNALIST TO REPORT THE
EXISTENCE OF CHRISTOPHER
STEELE'S DIRTY DOSSIER IN
THE LEAD-UP TO THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
SO, LET'S KEEP TRACK OF
COMEY'S LEADERSHIP AT THE
FBI.
YOU KNOW, MR. INTEGRITY.
OKAY, NOW, OF COURSE WE KNOW
COMEY HIMSELF WAS FIRED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HIS SECOND IN COMMANDS
ANDREW MCCABE WAS FIRED FOR
LYING.
ANDREW MCCABE IS NOW
CURRENTLY UNDER A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION COMEY'S TOP
INVESTIGATOR PETER STRZOK
WAS FIRED FOR HIS OBVIOUS
POLITICAL BIAS.
HE MAY SOON BE UNDER
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION AS
WELL AS HIS EX-GIRLFRIEND
TOP FBI LAWYER LISA PAGE.
SHE WAS FORCED TO RESIGN
OVER HER BIAS THEN HAVE YOU
COMEY'S CHIEF OF STAFF JAMES
RYBICKI HE HAS RESIGNED AND
NOW WE KNOW COMEYY'S GENERAL
COUNSEL JIM BAKER NOW WE CAN
REPORT UNDER AN OFFICIAL
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
SOMETHING COMEY HIMSELF THAT
HE ADMITTED TO DOING WHEN HE
LEAKED THE FBI MEMOS ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, REMEMBER,
TO HIS PROFESSOR FRIEND AT
COLUMBIA THEN TO THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" FOR THE VERY
PURPOSE OF SPURRING A
SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION WHICH COINS
DENTALLY BEING CARRIED OUT
BY COMEY'S CLOSE FRIEND
ROBERT MUELLER.
HOW NICE.
SO, WHAT DID ALL THE PEOPLE,
I JUST LIST, HAVE IN COMMON?
, THEY ALL WANTED HILLARY
CLINTON TO WIN ONE OF THEM
100 MILLION TO ZERO.
THEY ALL HATED AND CONTINUE
TO HATE DONALD TRUMP.
THEY ALL WORK TOGETHER TO
RIG OUR POLITICAL SYSTEM AND
FIX OUT OUTCOME OF THE 2016
ELECTION BY USING THEIR
POWERFUL TOP POSITION, NOT
RANK AND FILE, THE TOP
POSITION, THE FBI AND THE
DOJ TO HELP HILLARY CLINTON
WIN, TO CHEAT, TO RIG AN
ELECTION.
AND AS WE NOW KNOW THEY HAD
AN EMERGENCY POLICY AND A
MEDIA LEAK STRATEGY IN CASE
CLINTON DIDN'T WIN
100 MILLION TO ZERO.
AFTER COMEY WAS FIRED TOP
OFFICIALS INSIDE OUT FBI
WERE ANGRY.
THEY ACTED OUT OF THAT
ANGER, MALICE EMOTION
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE, NO
PROBABLE CAUSE OR REASONABLE
SUSPICION AND ENDED UP WHAT
WAS A PARTISAN INVESTIGATION
INTO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WITH A WILD
CONSPIRACY ACCUSING THE
PRESIDENT OF WORKING WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN TO FIRE COMEY
BECAUSE RUSSIA TOLD HIM TO
DO IT.
NO EVIDENCE THEY WERE ANGRY.
THIS WAS THEIR PUNISHMENT.
THIS WAS THEIR PAY BACK
ABUSING POWER TO ATTACK THE
PRESIDENT THAT THEY NEVER
WANT ELECTED.
THIS BRINGS US TONIGHT TO A
HANNITY HISTORY LESSON.
GREEN GREENWALD RECENTLY
POINTED OUT THAT THE FBI IN
THEIR INVESTIGATION INTO
DONALD TRUMP USED EERILY
SIMILAR TACTICS TO THOSE
PIONEERED BY J. EDGAR
HOOVER.
REMEMBER HOOVER SERVED AS
FBI DIRECTOR FOR DECADES AND
BECAME INFAMOUS FOR
AGGRESSIVE INVESTIGATION
INTO AMERICANS WHO HE
SUSPECTED HAD TIES TO THE
SOVIET UNION.
HOOVER EVEN SUSPECTED FDR'S
VICE PRESIDENT HENRY WALLACE
TO BE A LENGTHY PROBE AND
SURVEILLANCE SIMPLY BECAUSE
HOOVER DISAGREED WITH
WALLACE'S POLICY.
THE FBI SHOULD NEVER BE IN
THE BUSINESS OF
INVESTIGATING POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES OR POLICY
DECISIONS.
IT SHOULDN'T BE, WELL,
LASHING OUT BECAUSE OF
PERSONAL OPINIONS THAT THEY
HAVE.
THE ROLE OF THE FBI WHICH IS
THE 99% OF FIELD AGENTS OF
RANK AND FILE THEY DO THEIR
JOBS AND INVESTIGATE CRIMES
AND CRIMINALS.
NOT POLITICS, NOT POLICY AND
ESPECIALLY NOWFT LAUNCHING A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION INTO A DULY
ELECTED PUT WITH ZERO
EVIDENCE BECAUSE YOU DON'T
LIKE HIM.
TODAY WILLIAM BARR,
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PICK TO BE
THE NEXT ATTORNEY GENERAL
FACED HIS FIRST DAY OF
CONFIRMATION HEARINGS ON THE
HILL.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM WHO
WILL JOIN US LATER GRILLED
HIM ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT HE
WOULD INVESTIGATE THE FBI'S
BASELESS, CORRUPT
INVESTIGATION INTO PRESIDENT
TRUMP, TAKEN OUT OF ANGER
FOR THE FIRING OF COMEY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HUD ALWAYS BE ON GUARD
ABOUT THE POLITICIAN
INTERFERING IN AN
INVESTIGATION BUT WE SHOULD
ALSO HAVE OVERSIGHT OF HOW
THE DEPARTMENT WORKS AND
THOSE WITH ITS TREMENDOUS
POWER USE THAT POWER.
ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH THE
JANUARY 11st "NEW YORK
TIMES" ARTICLE ABOUT FBI
OPEN INQUIRY INTO WHETHER
TRUMP WAS SECRETLY WORKING
ON BEHALF OF RUSSIANS?
>> YES, MR. CHAIRMAN.
>> WOULD YOU PROMISE ME AND
THIS COMMITTEE TO LOOK INTO
THIS AND TELL US WHETHER OR
NOT, IN THE APPROPRIATE WAY,
A COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION WAS OPENED UP
BY SOMEBODY AT THE FBI,
SLASH DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> YES, MR. CHAIRMAN.
I THINK THERE WERE A NUMBER
OF INVESTIGATIONS AS I
UNDERSTAND IT GOING ON IN
THE DEPARTMENT.
>> HAVE YOU EVER HEARD OF
SUCH A THING IN ALL THE TIME
YOU HAVE BEEN ASSOCIATED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE?
>> I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF
THAT.
>> ARE THERE RULES ABOUT HOW
YOU CAN DO
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATIONS?
>> I BELIEVE THERE ARE
MR. CHAIRMAN.
>> SO IF YOU WANT TO OPEN UP
ONE AGAINST THE PRESIDENT
ARE THERE ANY CHECK AND
BALANCES?
>> NOT OUTSIDE THE FBI.
>> WELL, WE NEED TO LOOJ AT
THAT.
IN TERMS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY ENFORCING THE LAW,
DON'T WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE AN
AGENDA?
>> THAT'S RIGHT,
MR. CHAIRMAN.
>> DO YOU PROMISE ME AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL IF YOU GET
THIS JOB TO LOOK INTO SEE
WHAT HAPPENED IN 2016?
>> YES, MR. CHAIRMAN.
>> Sean: THAT'S A GOOD SIGN
THAT WILLIAM BARR CARES
ABOUT EQUAL JUSTICE AND
APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS AND
SAYING HE WILL SERVE AS A
FAIR ATTORNEY GENERAL.
MR. BARR, THERE ARE NO
SHORTAGE OF CORRUPT TRUMP
HATERS TO INVESTIGATE AND
MANY WITH A LOT OF POWER
THAT THEY HAVE ABUSE YOU
HAD.
NO SHORTAGE OF CRIMES HERE.
TONIGHT WE ARE GOING TO
BEGIN TO LAY OUT A ROAD MAP
OF CORRUPTION FOR THE NEW
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO BE OUR
OWN GREGG JARRETT HAS
COMPILED A COMPREHENSIVE
LIST.
TO START WE ARE NOT GO
THROUGH THE FULL LIST
TONIGHT WITH FISA ABUSE.
THAT IS LYING TO A FISA
COURT.
THAT IS COMMITTING A FRAUD
AGAINST A COURT TO GET A
WARRANT TO SPY ON A TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE USING
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR PHONY DOSSIER THAT
WAS FULL OF RUSSIAN LIES.
JAMES COMEY, AN GRIEWF
MCCABE, SALLY YATES ROD
ROSEN SOMETIME ALL COMMITTED
CRIME ON A FISA COURT
PRESENTING HILLARY CLINTON'S
DIRTY DOSSIER BIASED.
IT WAS NEVER VERIFIED, NEVER
CORROBORATED AND FULL OF
RUSSIAN LIES AND THEY NEVER
TOLD THE COURTS THAT IT WAS
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY
HILLARY CLINTON.
NEXT UP, MR. BARR, YOU GET
THIS JOB YOU NEED TO LOOK
INTO THE THEFT AND LEAKING
OF GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS.
JIM COMEY OBVIOUSLY
COMMITTED A SERIOUS CRIME
WHEN HE INTENTIONALLY LEAKED
HIS FBI MEMOS ABOUT HIS
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ALSO LOOK
AT ABUSE OF POWER CHANGES
THAT WOULD BE COMEY, MCCABE,
STRZOK, ALL FIRED, LISA
ENGAGE.
BRUCE ORH SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED TWICE.
DISAGREE WITH POLITICALLY
ALL TRYING TO GET HILLARY
CLINTON ELECTED AND THEN
HAVING AN INSURANCE POLICY,
AND A MEDIA LEAK STRATEGY
IF, IN FACT, DONALD TRUMP
DID WIN.
LET'S NOT FORGET ABOUT LYING
TO THE FBI.
AFTER ALL, THIS CRIME
SHOULDN'T ONLY APPLY AN
AMERICAN WAR HERO LIKE
GENERAL FLYNN AND TRUMP
CAMPAIGN STAFF LIKE GEORGE.
ANDREW MCCABE WAS FIRED OVER
THAT CHARGE.
IS HE GOING TO RECEIVE THE
SAME TREATMENT AS GENERAL
FLYNN AND BE PROSECUTED.
THE DOJ ALSO WILL NEED TO
TACKLE THE UNAUTHORIZED
LEAKS.
WE NOW KNOW THAT JAMES BAKER
IS ALREADY FACING A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION TONIGHT OVER
THIS CHARGE BUT SO, TOO ARE
WE GOING TO LOOK OUGHT JOHN
BRENNAN AND JAMES CLAPPER
AND WHAT ABOUT SUSAN RICE
AND SAMANTHA POWERS.
SHOULD THEY BE INVESTIGATED
OVER THE MARV AMOUNTS OF
NAMES THAT THEY UNHAVOCKED
WHILE SERVING IN THE FINAL
YEAR OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
AND BECAUSE OF JAMES COMEY'S
BIASED AND INHE WANT
INVESTIGATION OF HILLARY
CLINTON EXONERATION BEFORE
INVESTIGATION OBVIOUS
VIOLATION OF THE ESPIONAGE
ACT, MR. BARR MUST ALSO
REVISIT HILLARY CLINTON'S
VARIOUS DRIMENT.
LIKE OH E THE DELETING YOUR
EMAILS AND HARD DRIVE AND
WASHING IT WITH BLEACH BIT
AND BUSTS UP DEVICES AND
RIPPING OUT SIM CARDS.
WE WILL SHOW YOU HOW
MR. BARR SHOULD TACKLE THAT
IN TOMORROW NIGHT'S
MONOLOGUE.
GET BACK TO BARR'S TESTIMONY
ON CAPITOL HILL EARLIER
TODAY IN A CONCERNING
STATEMENT HE ACTUALLY SAID
THAT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION IS NOT A
WITCH-HUNT.
I STRONGLY DISAGREE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU SAY YOU HAVE KNOWN
MUELLER A LONG TIME.
>> WOULD YOU SAY YOU HAVE A
CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH
MR. MUELLER?
>> I WOULD SAY WE WERE GOOD
FRIENDS.
>> WOULD YOU SAY THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND HIM TO BE A
FAIR-MINDED PERSON?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> DO YOU TRUST HIM TO BE
FAIR TO THE PRESIDENT AND
THE COUNTRY AS A WHOLE?
>> YES.
>> WHEN HIS REPORT COMES TO
YOU, WILL YOU SHARE IT WITH
US AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE?
>> CONSISTENT WITH THE
REGULATIONS AND THE LAW,
YES.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE
MR. MUELLER WOULD BE
INVOLVED IN A WITCH-HUNT
AGAINST ANYBODY?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE
MR. MUELLER WOULD BE
INVOLVED IN A WITCH-HUNT.
>> Sean: MAYBE WE CAN ASSUME
BAR IS TRYING TO PLACATE
DEMOCRATIC FEARS GIVING THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
NOT RUSHING TO JUSTICE.
A IN THE UNTIL PROOSM
GUILTY.
WE KNOW ROBERTS MUELLER IS
ON A WITCH-HUNT.
LOOK NO FURTHER THAN THE
PEOPLE MUELLER HIRED.
MULTIPLE BIG TIME DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS THOSE WHO MADE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
COMBINED IN CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE CAMPAIGNS OF OBAMA,
KERRY, CLINTON, AND OTHER
DEMOCRATS.
MUELLER HE HIRED ZERO
REPUBLICANS.
NOT ONE ATTORNEY WORKED FOR
HILLARY CLINTON WHO WORKED
FOR HILLARY CLINTON.
HOW COULD YOU HIRE HILLARY
CLINTON'S ATTORNEY AT THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION?
AND MUELLER'S SO-CALLED PIT
BULL ACCORDING TO THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" ANDREW
WEISSMANN?
HE ACTUALLY ATTENDED
HILLARY'S ELECTION NIGHT
PARTY.
AND WEISSMANN HAS ALSO COME
UNDER FIRE FOR HIS AGGRESSIVE
PROSECUTION TACTICS
WITHHOLDING IF YOU WITHHOLD.
EXCAN A PA TORE EVIDENCE.
ONE CASE FORCED TO CLOSE
THEIR DOORS, TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LOST
THEIR JOBS BEFORE THE
SUPREME COURT OVERTURNED
WEISSMANN'S PROSECUTION
9-100.
IN ANOTHER CASE, MUELLER'S
PIT BULL WEISSMANN SAID FOUR
INNOCENT MERRILL LYNCH TO
PRISONER FOR A YEAR.
NEVER GET THAT YOUR BACK IN
YOUR LIFE.
BEFORE THAT CASE WAS
OVERTURNED BY THE FIFTH
CIRCUIT OF APPEALS.
WE ARE SUPPOSE TO BELIEVE
THAT THAT TRACK RECORD
AROINTING THOSE PEOPLE ARE
FAIR BASED INVESTIGATION AS
CARRIED OUT BY AN OBVIOUS
AGGRESSIVE PARTISAN TEAM E
LAWYERS THAT MUELLER PICKED.
HE ALSO PICKED STRZOK AND
PAGE.
WE KNOW WHERE THEY STAND.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR
ALL THE LATEST DEVELOPMENTS
SURROUNDING THE DEEP STATE
THROUGHOUT THE SHOW TONIGHT.
TURN TO HANNITY WATCH ON THE
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
TODAY PRESIDENT TRUMP
INVITED DEMOCRATS TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
IS HE TRYING TO MAKE A DEAL.
HE IS OFFERING THEM EVERY
OPPORTUNITY, INVITED THEM TO
LUNCH AND A MEETING TO
DISCUSS BORDER SECURITY.
THAT INVITATION ONCE AGAIN
BY, OH, I WILL GIVE YOU A
DOLLAR NANCY PELOSI AND
COMPANY.
MAKING IT ALL THE MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THE PUTZ TO
NEGOTIATE WITH A GROUP OF
PEOPLE HOW FAR DO YOU
NEGOTIATE WHEN THEY WON'T
COME TO THE TABLE TO TALK?
THIS COMES AS A NEW MIGRANT
CARAVAN IS ON THE MOVE NOW
TONIGHT IN HONDURAS
ACCORDING TO A HUMAN RIGHT
GROUP THE CARE OF VAN HAS
WARMED TO 2,000 INDIVIDUALS.
RACING MORE CONCERNS ABOUT
MORE DOLLARSS.
>> REPORTS BACK UP TO THE
UNITED STATES WITHOUT A
DOUBT THIS IS GOOD FOR
EVERYBODY ON BOTH SIDES YOU
HAVE OUR BURDEN IF WE HAD
PHYSICAL BARRIERS.
REMEMBER, A WALL MAKES
EVERYBODY SAFE.
WE DON'T WANT TO ENCOURAGE
THE JOURNEY WHICH IS
LITERALLY DIFFICULT PEOPLE
DIE.
WHICH IS SUBJECT TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
PHYSICAL ABUSE, SEXUAL
ABUSE.
THOSE WHO WANT TO COME HERE
FOR A BETTER LIFE.
I HAVE SET MANY TIMES I WANT
A BETTER LIFE FOR THEMSELVES
THEIR KIDS AND GRAND KIDS.
WE HAVE GOT TO HAVE A SYSTEM
WHERE WE VET ANYONE AND
EVERYONE TRYING TO COME INTO
OUR COUNTRY.
WE HAVE HAD AMERICANS THAT
HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES
BECAUSE OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
90% OF THE DRUGS, HEROIN,
FOR EXAMPLE, COMING INTO
THIS COUNTRY COME FROM OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THAT MAKES IT A LIFE AND
DEATH METER.
NOIFT A POLITIC EMPLOYEES.
HAPPY DEMOCRATS SHOULD TAKE
NOTE.
GOOD NEWS ON THE ECONOMIC
FRONT TONIGHT.
GERMAN AUTOMAKER VOLKSWAGEN
ANNOUNCED EXPANDING
OPERATIONS IN TENNESSEE
THAT'S GOOD NEWS FOLLOWING
THE NEWS THE PRESIDENT
TWEETED OUT VOLKSWAGEN WILL
BE SPENDING $800 MILLION IN
CHATTANOOGA, TENNESSEE AND
THEY WILL BE MAKING ELECTRIC
CARS.
CONGRATULATIONS TO
CHATTANOOGA AND TENNESSEE.
A JOB WELL DONE.
A BIG WIN.
AND IT GETS BETTER A NEW
POLL FINDING THAT OVER 7 IN
10 INVESTORS, THE ECONOMIC
FUNDAMENTALS HAS STRONG AND
LONG-TERM OPTIMISM REMAINING
HIGH.
DEMOCRAT STRENGTHENED TO
DESTROY ALL THAT OPTIMISM
WITH THEIR FAR LEFT NANNY
STATE SOCIALIST DREAMS.
LIKE DEMOCRATIC PAIR OF NEW
YORK COMRADE BILL DE BLASIO,
ACTUALLY PUSHING A NEW PLAN
TO CONFISCATE PRIVATE PARTY
FROM LANDLORDS.
THOSE HE CLAIMS CREATES
UNLIVABLE CONDITIONS.
AND HE IS EVEN SAYING WEALTH
IS IN THE WRONG HANDLE OF
THE PEOPLE OF NEW YORK.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE HE WANTS TO
CONFISCATE MONEY FROM SOME
PEOPLE AND REDISTRIBUTE IT
TO OTHER PEOPLE.
COASTAL COMRADES OUT IN
CALIFORNIA THEY ARE NOW
PUSHING THEIR OWN RADICAL
FAR LEFT AGENDA WITH ANOTHER
NANNY STATE PROPOSAL TO BAN
PAPER RECEIPTS BECAUSE
PEOPLE IS STILL HOLD TOXINS.
AMERICA BETTER WAKE UP.
SOCIALISM IS ON THE MOVE AND
TAKING OVER THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
UNEMPLOYMENT WOMEN IN THE
WORKFORCE, CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE REMAINS HIGH.
WAGE GROWTH IS THE BEST IT
HAS BEEN IN A DECADE.
BUT DEMOCRATS THREATENING TO
TURN BACK ALL THIS PROGRESS,
HIGHER TAXES, BURDEN SON
REGULATION AND, OF COURSE,
THEY DON'T WANT ANY ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
SOME WANT A 70 OR 08% TAX
RATE.
SOCIALIZED MEDICINE U
GOVERNMENT MANDATED CRIMENTD
CHANGE ALL WHILE MAKING OUR
NATION SAY LESS SECURE
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO FIRE
ICE AND WANTS OPEN BORDERS.
THEY WANT TO CONTROL YOUR
BUSINESS.